with covet cases on the decline more of
us are getting back to normal life
but normal life is getting more
expensive the labor department's
consumer price index rose 5
in may compared with one year earlier
that's the largest 12-month jump in
inflation since
2008. cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us with more joe good
morning to you
what areas of the economy are seeing the
biggest increases in prices
well as you would expect those that were
hit hardest by the pandemic are bouncing
back
most quickly so energy is up
dramatically
but also we are seeing used cars and
trucks
that accounted for about a third of the
overall increase
we are seeing airfares hotel room rates
are up
but it goes beyond that home furnishings
beef this is across the board and
clearly it is going to cost consumers
more when they go shopping for pretty
much anything right now
and joe what's behind it
well i think there's three basic
premises here number one
we are comparing where we are today to
where we were
a year ago and the economy was pretty
much shut down then
economists are saying to me look let's
go back to 2019.
prices are up from there but only by two
and a half percent it doesn't seem so
bad there have also been supply chain
issues that's created bottlenecks hard
to get your hands on a lot of goods and
services
because of that and finally us
we are actually going out and shopping
post pandemic
we're pushing up those prices so we've
got a lot of demand that's at work here
tony
jill we saw supply chain issues all the
way through the pandemic i'm
i'm surprised that they haven't started
easing up at this point
why aren't they and how much longer do
you think we're going to have them
well you know economists tell me that
these are issues that
are actually months in the making it's
kind of like hard to turn
around a big cruise ship on a dime so
what has happened is early in the
pandemic
there were safety protocols that created
bottlenecks as those got worked out
we had producers making big decisions so
imagine
you're a semiconductor chip maker and
it's the beginning of the pandemic what
do you think i only have a limited
amount of people and production
what am i going to do i'm going to focus
on consumer electronics
what did that leave out cars and trucks
well who's going to want a car and truck
they figured
a lot of people and so as a result those
supply chain issues
are exacerbated it is going to take
months
longer to have those work themselves out
you know the other issue i see jill is
that everything is on back order even if
you can try to find it i don't care what
you're ordering
everything is on back order can you help
me understand why that is and
how much longer do you think the higher
prices are going to last but
talk about the back oh the back order
thing is so hard well okay what the
problem is again is that because there
weren't enough materials made
it has actually created a lack of supply
but all of a sudden
there's this enormous demand it's just
the worst case scenario for a producer
those backlogs are expected to persist
i'm tell i'm told by construction folks
that this is at least another six months
before things get worked out on that end
overall how long will inflation stay
elevated well
some economists think that we've just
seen the peak we have got to see
this could take longer that is something
that can really
make the economy overall be problematic
why because if we see persistent
inflation
the federal reserve may step in and
start to raise interest rates
and that could snuff out our beautiful
recovery that we are in the middle of
right now so joe can you help me
understand why if you checked your
retirement account yesterday you might
have noticed that the stock market
reached a new high
looks great on that front and yet we
have this bad news about rising prices
how can they be one in the same and if
the prices continue to go up
could it drag the stock market down
well i always like to say the stock
market's like the bizarro world so
if you're a big investor maybe you would
worry about rising prices
and that maybe uh that the fed would act
and slow the economy down
but investors are really looking at the
federal reserve
they say the fed is going to let
inflation run a little bit hotter
and as a result there should be not a
lot of movement in the economy or
stocks long-term investors don't touch
your portfolios please
as actually stocks do pretty well in
higher inflation environments as long as
you don't become reactive so stay
the course i know you're always saying
keep calm and carry on you're like the
queen jill
you like the queen thank you very much
thank you